president biden taking his first
major action on gun control and he's
causing controversy for what he said
about the second amendment
today biden rolled out a series of six
executive orders
to stop what the white house is calling
a quote
gun violence public health epidemic end
quote
and the president saying that's just the
start of what he wants to do
watch this gun violence in this country
is an epidemic
and it's an international embarrassment
nothing nothing i'm about to recommend
in any way impinges on the second
amendment
they're phony arguments suggesting that
these are second amendment rights at
stake from what we're talking about
but no amendment no amendment to the
constitution is absolute
we should also ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines in this country
we should also eliminate gun
manufacturers from the immunity they
received from the congress
it passed not a single new federal law
to reduce gun violence
enough prayers time for some action
biden also nominating a strong gun
control advocate to
head the atf but critics are saying
that david chipman's past comments are a
problem
he appeared once to mock americans who
bought guns during the pandemic
take a look they might think that their
die hard ready to go
but unfortunately they're more like
tiger king and
they're putting themselves and their
families in danger
and so what i would suggest is for those
people who were first-time gun owners if
they did
go out and buy a gun i would secure that
gun
locked and unloaded and hide it behind
the cans of tuna and beef jerky that
you've stored in a cabinet
and you know only bring that out if
the zombies start to appear um and i
don't think they are
uh dana i was just looking over some of
the proposals
it strikes me that biden's proposal
seemed pretty moderate
along the lines of what president trump
did after the vegas shooting by
you know saying we need to maybe reign
in the use and sale of bump stocks
what do you think well it could be that
you know what he's proposing to do by
executive order is actually
fairly um i mean maybe uh anodyne right
so
he talks about having a model red flag
law that other states could pick up
it's not the executive orders that he's
talking about that are causing the
uproar today it's that when he said
there's
actually no amendment his sacrament i'm
like wow even the first like
that would be uh really newsy um
in addition to that there's something
else happened this morning senator joe
manchin of west virginia
had an op-ed in the washington post in
which he said i will not
vote to end the filibuster end of story
what i think could have happened here on
gun control is that biden realized that
he was not going to be able to propose
legislation in congress that would ever
get anywhere
and then the left was going to
constantly say you're not doing enough
you're not doing enough and so
instead what he's trying here is what
charles cook of national review just
called
an anemic end run around the congress my
last point is
that this is another example of
president biden's school of governing
so he will go out and give a speech on a
very important topic and say
you know this is an existential threat
we've got to do something about it
and then he'll talk a really big game
about bipartisanship and say we really
can work together that's how i
ran for president i was in the senate i
know how to do this to
work with republicans my hand is
outreach but instead what's happening in
his hand is under the table and he flips
it over and the republicans are just
left there saying wait wait i thought
that we were going to work together on
something anything
and it turns out that they just might
not
yeah it doesn't look good so greg you
know what strikes me is we have had a
series of
you know big shootings i ate in uh
georgia 10 people dead in colorado
more dead california but it looks like
this has become a culture wars issue to
dana's point
you know people just don't seem to be
able to talk and get anything done
why is this you know the case that this
is a culture wars issue when we're
talking about life and death
because the democrats
cannot speak honestly about this
biden used the phrase gun violence
public health epidemic
those are five words when one word would
do that one word is
criminals right criminals
the overwhelming majority 99.9999
of the crime is done by criminals or you
can use three words like law and order
you could save a lot of time the gun
violence is directly related to the
to the overall rise in crime due to the
defund movement and the ferguson effect
we've seen a dearth of police a pullback
in policing we've seen even cnn admit
that there's a drastic spike in crime in
shootings and homicides in all the major
democratic lead cities
so if you think attacks on pistols
with stabilizing braces would have saved
the lives of the
extra 100 killed in memphis this year
plus 100 you're crazy if you think that
turning lawful gun owners
uh into felons would have prevented the
deaths of the elderly asians
in oakland california or new york city
some of whom were actually stabbed
you're nuts if joe really means what he
means
what he should do is arrest his son you
know for lying on the atf forum
four four seven three you don't enforce
that you don't have the right to enforce
anything else frankly
and to to dana's point it is anodized
these are these are not real efforts
they're they're symbolic and i'm okay
with symbolic right
but uh if you start focusing on the
lawful owner
while you brazenly ignore the crime
that's going around in this country that
is destroying this country
uh that's that's criminal
okay so kennedy uh one area where there
seems to be some agreement
and this is one of biden's proposals
today is that when you have these
so-called
ghost guns guns that be can be
constructed from
a kit um that they should have serial
numbers on them
do you think that might be something
everybody can say yeah okay let's do
that
no i've shot a 3d printed gun and there
are going to be all sorts of ways
that anyone with a cnc machine will get
around federal regulations
and that's essentially what they're
doing with this new category that has
been constructed
and people who use the term don't really
know what they're talking about
like when they use the term assault
weapons and i think it's really vague i
think it's nebulous i think it's
ill-defined
and i think it's something that's
applied out of political convenience
my biggest issue here is with yet
another bureaucrat
who has never really spent time in the
middle of the country david chipman
uh he's he's heading the atf and he
obviously
hates people who respect the
constitution
and feel they need to have some form of
self-defense in their homes because
guess what if you live in a rural area
or if you live
in a big city like minneapolis or
portland the police may not come when
you call them you know you may have a
911 emergency
and and how long are you supposed to
wait 20 minutes
uh do you tell someone who's broken into
your home who's
threatening your life and your
children's lives hold on a second let's
wait till the cops get here that's not
necessarily how it works and rational
people in this country know that you
can't always wait for the police
but what we know now is responsible gun
owners are being lumped
into this category where they're being
made out to be
murderous hillbillies and it's very
offensive
so will the house of representatives
passed two bills
last week on guns and
sent it on to the senate not so far no
action
the president said today you know you
guys are always giving us thoughts and
prayers
but you don't do anything is there
anything will would do
well the will of the people does not
support the house's bill nor
joe biden's executive actions listen
juan the most important part of this
story was joe biden's statement there at
the beginning because it laid bare the
democratic playbook if you can't win an
argument stop arguing change the
language
that's exactly what just happened and
you cannot win because in a year when
violence is uh police funding is down
and gun ownership is an all-time high
you won't win something democratically
you have to go through executive order
and make no mistake the language is
what's being changed when joe biden said
you have a public health epidemic that
is a very important phrase because in
the past year we've sacrificed all
manner of freedoms
and rights at the altar of an epidemic
to classify
gun violence as an epidemic allows him
to take all types of authoritarian power
to deal with gun control what more they
learned from georgia
tell lies as dana or kennedy pointed out
assault weapons is a made-up term that
doesn't help define the lethality of a
weapon and distinguish it from the vast
majority of weapons everyone owns
finally
juan the constitution the constitution
doesn't require me to prove to joe biden
why i need something
it requires him to prove to me why he
needs to take it away and to greg's
point
whether or not it will help solve gun
violence i think he hasn't answered that
i don't think he's answered the
democratic process i don't think he can
win an argument
and that's why he's once again changing
language and telling lies
okay strong letter to follow will